a South African peacekeeping Convoy
patrols the road between sake and GMA in
the Eastern Democratic Republic of Congo
it's part of a South African Regional
Mission supporting congales soldiers to
protect the North kuu Capital GMA from
advancing M23 Rebels thousands of people
have been forced to leave Villages
around sake during heavy
fighting we saw soldiers running away
from their positions as fighting erupted
between them and the rebels that's why
we left the fighting was too intense in
the
city the situation in sake is very bad
with heavy fighting between soldiers and
M23 Rebels they' have attacked with
heavy guns and bombs fell on the city
this is why we are leaving for
G government soldiers and un
peacekeepers have been struggling to
contain M23 Rebels since late 2021 when
the armed group relaunched its
Rebellion the United Nations backs
government accusations that Randa is
supporting the fighters but Randa denies
this as you know the situation on the
ground is very worrying and alarming it
raises the risk of a regional explosion
or at any rate of a very strong
intensification with a regional
characteristic or an increased Regional
component with the involvement of
different countries in the region to a
greater
extent
president Felix shisi promised to deal
with the violence in eastern Congo
during his reelection campaign but
barely a month since he won December
elections Rebels are defying his
authority the UN has urged the
government to send reinforcements to
iuri North and South kevu provinces as
peacekeepers prepare to withdraw from
the DRC by the end of the year Barbara
Anga Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer